[Music]
my guest this week is an economics
professor who according to his Twitter
bio was quietly writing obscure academic
texts for years until he was thrust onto
the public scene by Europe's and named
handling of an inevitable crisis Yanis
varoufakis welcome to the Rubin report
it's great to be here thank you Yanis
varoufakis I mean Greek people have by
far the best names on earth is that fair
to say nothing the slightest you should
have seen what kind of life I lived in
Britain as a young person with a nicer
name like mine yeah did is what your dad
constantly oh yeah you can imagine um
you know strategically as well I'm sure
strategically alright so you are in
Athens right now and we are gonna do a
lot on Greece and I just mentioned to
you before we started I haven't done
much on Greece even though it's really
right in the center of everything
happening economically in the world and
everything going on in the EU right now
and everything else so for the people
that know nothing about Greece can you
explain why your Twitter bio says what
it says well back in the late 1990s a
remarkable experiment in monetary
economics took place in Europe in our
great infinite wisdom we Europeans tried
to bind monetarily together very
disparate economies without any
mechanism for recycling surpluses for
keeping checks and balances in capital
inflows and outflows any kind of
economic union was skewed sort of put on
the back burner while pushing forward
the monetary and whenever you bind
together different economies monetarily
we've seen this with a Gold Exchange
standard in the mid war period we've
seen it with various pegs between the
United States dollar and various Central
and Latin American currencies we saw it
in Europe in the 1980s and early 1990s
with the European
change rate mechanism where you try to
put together to effectively effective to
fix exchange rates without completing
the political union the fiscal union the
banking union the banking is being the
most important you know you need to have
a single banking sector throughout the
one currency area so when you do that
what happens is the first few months
years resemble this is an allegory that
I use it resembles invading Russia think
of Napoleon think of Hitler's a
wonderful beginning you know the truth
store across to the steps right
it all looks fantastic it's working and
then at some point bitter winter takes
hold and it ends up very badly with
blood on the snow and so on and so Oscar
pollen and so you're exactly simply what
happens is it in every economy in every
currency union there are surplus areas
that is the producer this is like
California and there are deficit areas
like misery
I mean Europe its Germany and Greece
within Germany it's Easter Germany and
western Germany there will always be
surplus producers and deficit producers
and when that happens in a monetary
union there is a tendency for the
surpluses to travel from the banks where
they accumulate to the deficit areas in
the form of loans why it's all every day
every time a Greek bought a Volkswagen
or a BMW a certain amount of money went
to the Frankfurt banks from the Greek
banks because by definition Germany
always had always will have a trade
surplus with the place like Greece there
is going to be excess capital
accumulation the frankfurt banks what do
bankers do when they have excess capital
later levels or private debt very low
the lowest in the world we're at least
in developed world bankers look at even
the poor greek family that have their
own home and they have no debt anything
these are fantastic customers
they are not indebted and they have
collateral meant them so it's tsunami of
capital goes from the surface country to
the deficit country this because there
is a reason why Greece the deficit
countries because we have far less open
industrialization success story
happening in other words we have small
firms that cannot compete incredibles
with large conglomerates of Zeman's and
Fox wagon and I gay and so on the money
comes in and it effectively bigs up
asset prices how prices and various
other known produced producing not
non-productive assets that creates
semblance of growth people's real think
that oh my god my house is now worth
double what it was so they get another
loan they get another credit card and
that means that they buy more folks
working so the Germans are happy the
Greeks are happy but this is the
invading Russia part when everything
looks Hankey Dori when it really is
nothing other than a Ponzi scheme it is
a debt fueled pseudo growth situation
and then eventually something happens
usually beginning with Wall Street and
like you did in 2008 like a four that
happen I 9 20 9 whatever the reason is
that there is a pin that pricks Lee the
bubble the bubble bursts and then what
happens what happens is exactly what
happened in 1930s the greatest burden
for Justin falls on the weakest of
shoulders the Greek shoulders the
Portuguese shoulders the Irish sore
shoulders and then suddenly the surplus
countries realize that they have
effectively created a lot of assets in
countries that are collapsing mm-hmm but
because you have a monetary union and
it's not just a fixed exchange rate it's
much harder than that because we don't
have just a peg between a Greek Ric and
the German carries we have the same damn
currency so you can't do what Argentina
did you cannot sever the peg and devalue
because you don't have a can assist
device you have to create your own
currency in order to divide you to do
you know this is like foreshadowing
devaluation a year before it happens
it's you just need to state it to
realize the
the extent of the costs involved and the
lamps that that would bring so what
happens is the alternative is internal
devaluation so the creditors come here
and this is the crime against logic that
was committed in May of 2010 we had the
Greek state bankrupt there was no way to
to rollover it's dead it did not have a
Knesset equal value and he did not have
a central bank
so imagine we're trying at States
imagine 2008 in the United States
without the Fed right and without a
capacity to divide the dollar even
visible again the the euro and so on and
so for them it just might complete and
utter madness right and so what did they
do in it you know it is quite
astonishing they came to the Greek state
and I said okay we'll bail you out but
of course it wasn't even bail out right
what they did was they gave to the Greek
state the largest amount in humanity's
history in absolute terms remember
Greece is a little pipsqueak of a
country it's a tiny little place 2% of
the European economy 2% is that the
Delaware I hope you're right yeah so
imagine imagine if the powers that be
the IMF the Fed the Treasury the World
Bank were to descend upon that away and
give the government of Delaware of the
state of Delaware the largest sum in
human history on conditions of austerity
that guarantee to shrink the income of
the people living there right now if you
are how do you need to be to realize
this cannot end well eight in a
barricade it's a little older in America
we're not that bright let's say 40 I
don't Excel arrogance understand
bankruptcy yeah but there appears we
understand bankruptcy you know what I
think that most Americans understand
that you cannot escape a bankruptcy
through loans you know you can escape a
crisis of liquidity three loans but you
cannot escape bankruptcy through loans
right especially when the loans are
given imagine imagine if Lehman Brothers
the missile files went to Hank Paulson
in 2008 as he did and he where to say to
him you know cap in hand helped me and
imagine if the answer was
I'm not going to bail you out I'm not
going to let you default ya compactor
and now but I'm going to give you a six
percent interest six percent think six
percent interest rate and in the middle
of the collapse right when interest
rates will crash into zero right I'll
give you a loan by which will make whole
all your creditors and you will get this
loan on condition that you will shrink
your revenues you know that I don't
think the Hank Paulson would ever
imagine of saying that right now boarded
Lehman Brothers but even though he hated
Lehman Brothers he would never have a
this is what happened with these right
so there isn't library C's in the news
since 2010 yes because of it of course
the reason why they did it so they were
not idiots they knew that this was not
going to work but it was an underhanded
way of saving Frances and Germans banks
because they had stupidly lent a lot of
money to the Greek nom government they
already had all the toxic derivatives
that I had amassed from the other side
of the Atlantic and they had already
been bailed out by the French and agree
and the German government that you know
five hundred billion American dollars
the German banks only a few months
before grace and then suddenly another
two hundred three hundred billion would
have to be given to them to compensate
for that the chain reaction that would
happen if Greece defaulted because then
you will be Portugal and beyond and so
so instead of doing the right thing
which is to say okay let the Greek state
default and take the pain of bankruptcy
and we will recapitalize the banks and
effective nationalize them do a tarp to
what happened in it instead of doing
that they lied to nineteen Parliament's
Jimmy James nineteen Parliament's the
parliaments of the eurozone they said
what we're going we out of solidarity we
have to help Greece overcome its
problems was not the case of helping
Greece overcome right right it was a
case of helping Deutsche Bank Societe
Generale finance bank overcome their
problems without telling the german
taxpayers that the Greek bailout was all
about their own banks so but you see
once you pin you could you commit this
crime against logic
it's like Macbeth you can't commit a
crime you have to commit a second crime
ever up the first so that's the second
bailout now I was elected me an
appointed by the Prime Minister finance
minister in order to stop this and to
say to them folks know no more we're not
going to get a third bailout from you
only to extend and the crisis into the
future pretending that we have salt so
that's more or less story all right so
you've given me a lot to work with there
so let's back up a little bit and start
at the beginning so when all this was
happening before the Federation came
together before the EU was coming
together before all the currency was
being mixed and all of that were their
voices in Greece were you one of the
voices that were saying guys this is not
going to work there were a few voices
but we were drowned out by a cacophony
of celebration at the prospect of
monetary union the reason is that they
were there was just too much at stake
in terms of various kinds of
profiteering that was being envisaged at
the time there were too many many vested
interests and come to think of it a
monetary unification is extremely
powerful as a weapon by various powerful
forces so if you think about in terms of
the German industry you know the
industry of the exporting the net
exporters they love the idea of a
monetary union because they don't have
to worry about constant evaluation let's
say of the Italian lira which constantly
resuscitates the competitiveness of fiat
cars Italian cars mm-hmm
so the the surplus countries have an
interest in monetary union but even in
the deficit countries which in the end
always end up suffering there is an
interesting class distinction social
class distinction so if you go to the
northern suburbs of athens the leafy
ones the nice apples with the beautiful
village a lot of tax-evading has gone
into building them but nevertheless you
know these are the rich Greeks they
hated the drachma because every time the
Dragonetti value
they're dollar value of their mansion or
the adult would diminish so they wanted
their own assets to be read the
nominated in Deutsche marks right and
let's face it the euro is a Dutch mark
right but they manage the the whole
system the whole establishment managed
to even convince the working class even
the labor unions think about it you are
a unionist you're ganna you spend the
year organizing a strike it's not an
easy job to organize a strike there's a
lot of hardship there's a lot of
backlash the work is going to strike the
lose income they managed to get a 5% pay
rise let's say yeah then two days later
there's a devaluation they lose it so
they work on also convinced that a hard
currency would be good for them now of
course that means that it takes a
certain illiteracy when it comes to
microeconomics of the conveyance of that
but it's not difficult to see how
somebody who sees their hard-earned
gains being depleted by devaluation with
a V the Deutsche one to say I want a
Dutch mark I want to be paid in deutsche
mark like the Germans are why shouldn't
I be so when you have this coalition of
different interests III remember when I
was I think articles
[Music]
articulating my and expressing my great
misapprehension about the euro I was
being treated as an eccentric and as
somebody who had not caught up the times
we're not understood that there is a new
paradigm now very scarce risk which
dissipated you know the stuff how much
of that then is also tied into just the
way politicians not only in Greece but
all over the world the way they operate
which is that they want sort of
short-term gains so in a way you know
they're saying oh well we want to help
these rich people in Athens they want to
feel good about their money and all that
and their property and all that stuff
and then we'll sort of put off what's
going to happen long term for somebody
else to deal with 20 years I'm guessing
they didn't think even if they knew what
was going to happen they didn't think it
was going to happen so quickly right so
it's also just sort of the way all of
our politicians are designed to act
that's correct but look this has always
been a problem with politics
liberal democracies have always favored
short-termism always but there is a huge
sea change from the 1970s onwards not
just in Greece in the United States
Europe everywhere and that is because of
financialization with the end of Bretton
Woods after the early 1970s and the
unshackling of finance the fact that
suddenly finance became sexy and
turbocharged through various instruments
that were being developed to take
advantage of the unshackling of finance
after the end of brotherhood what
happened was the relative power of the
financial sector grew inexorably visibly
the political sphere so the way I
understand capital is there are three
spheres of power which is the political
sphere the economic sphere the real
economic sphere young companies making
things and there is finance and power
the power balance between them
constantly shifts in the 1970s there was
a massive shift from away from the
political sphere to the financial sphere
to put it very bluntly if you were
President Eisenhower or JFK you had a
lot more power as a president than you
did as President Carter or indeed job W
Bush you know political Goods diminished
in value compared to financial goods and
that look it makes sense doesn't it the
best and the brightest were no longer
drawn to the political sphere because if
you really where you know 25 years old
you were up and coming you were smart
and so on and you wanted to change
things
it was much easier to change things but
you know by entering goldman sachs or
some other or if you know she want you
to be in politics you to go into the
International Monetary Fund then then
becoming a senator or a great member of
Holland so this is my response to your
question
that by the time we created the Euro the
and flooded the Western world the
quality of politicians had fallen had
subsided and the result was that
short-termism increased because we we
lack the leaders who can say you know
what my target groups focus groups tell
me right but that people want it but you
know I got compared for why because I
think wise right and I think that if I'd
managed to convince people that white
right then I'm going to be a month or
more long term successful politician we
didn't have these people anymore so it
really is it's almost like the it's like
a marriage made in hell between the
financial sector and the politicians
pretty much so when when the EU came
back to you guys and offered really what
was if anything I think you could
describe it as ransom more than anything
else they were gonna force Greece to
take it basically but was there was a
referendum on it right are you talking
about not 2015 when I was younger yeah
but look it's really very simple um
before we were elected our central bank
had started a bank run against our
banking sectors can you believe that
yeah it doesn't make that central banks
were created to stop bank runs right our
central bank which is the central bank
of Europe which is stationed in
Frankfurt intentionally began a bank run
in order to start pushing putting
pressure on the government that had not
been elected yet only because of the
opinion polls well and why why did they
want to do less fixate us before we were
elected because people like me we're
saying that once we get elected we'll go
to them and say folks we need to reboot
the the whole program for Greece mm-hmm
that this is not working when we need
three things first we need this
substantial data structure because
unless we have a substantial data
structure we are not going to be able to
have sensible budget surplus targets
because you know when I got into the
ministry I inherited the surplus target
of four and a half percent of GDP for
the next 15 years that has never
happened in capitalist history
for a country to have four and a half
percent budget serve especially a broken
economy like this if you try to extract
four and a half percent surplus from
this economy which is what's been having
now for five six years yeah it is sort
the only way to do it is by keep
increasing ratcheting up tax rates and
having your tax take diminish so here I
am a left-winger using Reaganite
argument and Africa for God's sakes
yeah you know just you have to realize
that this is things are so ridiculous in
Europe how did that feel how are you how
did that feel for you because I fully I
fully understand what you're saying
there you're now having to use logic
that traditionally you wouldn't have
used because they basically have a gun
to the head of your country well look
when things get really bad
common sense binds people of the left
and the right and vested interests
divided that was you know I even to this
day let me tell you what I mean what
happened to me silly weeks ago right I
was in what was i I was in it in fact I
was in fact remember which German sicker
because I've traveled a lot in Germany
listen so in the morning I addressed 600
German bankers in the afternoon actually
evening I addressed 1200 activists
left-wing activists Wow where might I am
Italians but I gave the same speech
exactly the same speech but very bottom
it was an experiment and I got a
standing ovation both from the bankers
and the left-wing activists this is how
you know where we are not here because
the left-right divide is a very
important one but in a function in
capitalism in a capitalism which has a
degree of eyetality about it and then it
is a question of the mission of income
between paper and capital between those
who argue that investment needs to be
kept up through state intervention three
muckateers who argue that the best thing
that the state can do is commit suicide
you know we can have these arguments but
capital has to be fine
for us and have these album intensity
when you are in the situation like we
are English today or induction in German
because this is a common case European
crisis this there's no room for
disagreement along the lines of Latin I
take my country hearing this I'm
speaking to you from Adams well there is
no conflict of interest there is no
class conflicts between capital and
labor now because you have enter premier
square dine because companies are
bankrupt well it's really bankrupt they
have no access to banks banks do not
operate as created institutions the
demand is constantly diminishing the tax
rates are constantly going up and they
are hanging on for their lives and they
do not want to fire workers did not want
to reduce their workers wages but they
can't make ends meet anyway and you have
this situation where you have trade
unions and employers getting together
and crying in each others arms so this
is the moment when the left-right divide
simply disappears it's a question of
common sense so when you have a bankrupt
state bankrupt banks bankrupt
corporations banker pension funds and
bankrupt households the only thing you
can do is you can say okay folks we must
stop extending it pretending this
bankruptcy through getting more loans
and conditions that shrink aggregate
demand further so this is the situation
we're facing and now and you mentioned
them the referendum that was an amazing
moment in world political history
because think about it here we here I
was going to the Eurogroup the Europe
purpose of my finance ministers informal
group that makes all the important
decisions in Europe in a completely
anti-democratic fashion but nevertheless
it's where it all happens yeah I want to
get here in a little bit and I am
presenting to them what I'll tell you
Larry Summers when it because he was one
of the people helping me I even went to
bed with Larry Summers for godsakes and
not literally I don't think right okay
goodness you know before it be misquoted
very easily you know no but you know I
used any anyone that could help me that
had some clouds internationally lighted
summers was excellent in that regard
because as i said when common sense is
the it is common
there's no sense there's no reason why
we should not collaborate
anyone who can help even with the Prince
of Darkness as I call Larry Thomas so
you know we had with Jeff Sachs like
some as Norman Lamont the former
Chancellor of the Exchequer in Britain
Finance Minister of Britain under the
Conservatives that was my team of
helpers and aides and advisers so I put
to the Eurogroup a proposal a
fully-fledged proposal for recovering
Greece that when Larry Summers read it
he said this is something a Wall Street
bankruptcy lawyer would have put
together it was that left-wing you know
not at all in other words right so I am
yeah and I'm going think about I'm going
to the IMF Christine Lagarde is there
Paul Thompson from the IMF people who
are supposed to be near liberals in the
parlance of the left and I'm saying to
them folks we need to reduce corporate
tax rates it's ridiculous to have 29 26
27 28 percent corporate tax rate
increase when in Bulgaria which is only
a short drive away it's 10 percent
mm-hmm
it is it used to have a sales tax taxes
23 percent in the country where people
can't afford to pay sales taxes the kind
of a voting block to buy anything
so let's reduce those tax rates let's
have a debt restructure let's remain
retain the surplus in the government
budget but reduce it so as not to choke
the private sector let's have a
Development Bank let's have a bad Bank
to deal with the NPS of non-performing
loan these are that isn't me and they
would strike me down and they would
demand increases in tax rates further
linkage which is what happened after a
result right they added more extended
pretend loans this is the new liberals
on the IMF now it was clear that they
had nothing to do with economics it was
all about power politics it was about
snuff out the government that they
didn't like it was a coup d'etat that's
what it was so we we took this to the
Greek people we said that ok the Europe
is proposing this package of supposed
measures and policies which we consider
to be catastrophic
yeah but you know basically 32 own you
forever pretty much mean owning a
depleting asset yeah it was
it would that you know my my problem was
during negotiations it was a unique
problem I think in history I was
negotiating with creditors that did not
want their money back because if you
want your money back you do what I said
we should be doing to allow the economy
to grow to get your money back mm-hmm
but it's not only we didn't know they
were doing they were they were happy to
sacrifice Greece in order to win Spain
and we want in order to win France in
Italy because this is a domino theory
that I have that if you give concessions
to Greece and the Spanish will want it
then the French would want it so Greece
was there was never a discussion serious
discussion about an economic policy for
helping Greece is covered they didn't
want gracious tariqa so it's it's mind
boggling and you sacrifice a whole
people in order to do to do what to
maintain an unsustainable monetary union
with France yeah fine
you see what will happen now in France
next is just watch it see how the
ceiling is that they did in Greece is
going to bite them in France so but but
as Democrats I said okay right I'm going
to go to the Greek people and I'm going
to put to the Greek people your proposal
and if the Greek people say yes I will
accept it because I'm a Democrat I will
hate it but I also said I will resign
personally and let somebody else who
believes in you do it right as we should
in a democracy and yeah and the the your
billion reacted to this do you know how
by closing down our banks mm-hmm shut
the banks down they deduce it's like the
Fed and refusing liquidity to Citibank
tomorrow morning sleeping is finished
gone it was all the ATM who cease to
function Yeah right this was the this
was virtually in the United States this
was like our only moment where he we
even heard about this because suddenly
for you know one day there were some
videos of people of Greek people going
to ATM machines and not getting our
money we didn't hear anything about any
of things that led up to it that's what
we heard about no we didn't hear about
anything after that so the only reason
why they did that was to have a week
before the referendum of effectively
blackmailing a Greek saying to them vote
yes to the to the euro groups measures
otherwise your bench will never open
again and why
am I saying this was a remarkable month
we had every single television channel
bombarding people with propaganda that
they should vote yes to save the country
and that is a way if they vote no it
will be Armageddon they could not get
access to their money I was a finance
minister that was responsible in the
eyes of everyone for the fact that the
banks had shut down even though it was
my doing it was the central banks
against me but nevertheless I I was it
was on my watch that all the banks
closed up and I I had approval ratings
of seventy five percent during that week
I we would go out on the street and
people would lift us on their drugs you
know why because they say we don't care
about our money in the bank it's a
question of dignity mm-hmm you can't say
yes to this it's a moment of truth it's
a moment of liberation it's a moment of
you know national sovereignty after all
you cannot impose upon us this kind of
kuda dine expect us to yield because we
lose our money stuff or mine and we've
got 62% of people voting no
unfortunately my prime minister that
night capitulated and I designed
[Music]
you